today for this very timely discussion in
some ways this Facebook live session
offers good news a technology-based
understanding of the viral structure of
the novel coronavirus has actually
accelerated vaccine design for kovat 19
we are all deeply affected by this
pandemic most of us working from home as
one example as you can perhaps tell from
the background behind me I'm working
from home as well I'm curious to know
where you are watching from and what you
came to learn please let us know in the
comments this is a discussion that I'm
very encouraged by we have with us today
two people on the frontlines of progress
in developing a vaccine for the novel
coronavirus we will find out a little
bit more today about when that vaccine
might be available the genome sequence
of the corona virus was published online
in January of this year my guests today
were the ones who reported on how the
virus gains entry to host cells using
technology to really understand the
structures at play they published this
work in a science paper on February 19th
just a month ago and already the
insights from that study are helping to
inform vaccines earlier this week is one
example the first phase one trial of an
MN are a vaccine for Co good 19:00 began
in Seattle Washington the Facebook live
today is really going to focus on the
vaccine and not on other aspects of the
coronavirus discussion the discussion
will last about half an hour and by the
time it's over you'll understand more
about where we are in vaccine
development for the novel coronavirus
and about what factors got us here so
quickly including technology past
coronavirus research that started long
before the pandemic and a ready vaccine
platform design let's get straight to
our guests Jason McClellan works at the
University of Texas at Austin his lab is
focused on understanding and visualizing
how hosts and pathogens interact and he
and his team used this information to
develop vaccines and immunotherapies
Jason thanks for being here today
I mean thanks so much Mary Barney Graham
is the deputy director and chief of the
viral pathogen assist laboratory at the
NIAID z-- vaccine Reese
Center he's the perfect person to be
speaking here today amid the pandemic he
provides oversight of candidate vaccines
in advanced development
Barney thanks for being here today
morning Megan thank you for having me
Jason to start today I'm wondering if
you can tell us a little bit about the
technology that you all use to better
visualize the novel coronavirus and how
that really set up those who would
create the vaccine for success sure
Megan so Barney I have been working on
coronaviruses since 2013 and in
collaboration with dr. Andrew Ward at
the Scripps Research Institute we
collectively were able to determine
structures of spike proteins from the
hk1 corona virus MERS coronavirus my lab
was unable to take that structural
information in designing mutations and
constructs that help better stabilize
the spike protein that's on the surface
of the virus and that ends up being a
very good antigen because it looks like
what's on the surface of the virus we
can train our bodies to recognize it and
a lot of that was was done involving
cryo-electron microscopy which has
really been a major advance the last
since 2012-2013 really providing new
ways to obtain structural information
Barney we already have a vaccine
candidate for the corona virus in phase
1 clinical trials in part thanks to the
structure work that Jason described can
you talk a little bit about how the
efforts to create this vaccine compared
to past efforts how much faster are we
moving here vaccine development is
usually measured in decades even some of
our most successful vaccines like human
papillomavirus HPV vaccine the way to
make that particle was discovered in the
early 90s but it didn't really become a
vaccine for use until the mid to late
2000s so the this work that Jason
described and what we're talking about
today harkens back to our work on RSV
that occurred between 2010 and 2012 and
in that in that situation we were
able to stabilize we were able to define
the structure of the F glycoprotein
which is similar to spike on
coronaviruses
and showed that stabilizing that in that
pre fusion conformation was made it a
better antigen made it a better vaccine
it took about three years to turn that
into a protein vaccine so that we could
do a clinical trial and we've now
published that clinical trial and it
shows that it indeed is a good vaccine
when we came to Zika in 2016 that was
our previous fastest effort and it took
about 200 days to go from starting the
program to injecting the first person
and in this case because we knew ahead
of time what to do we were able to get
started within about 60 days after
learning the sequence so science
published the paper that you all are
referring to today a month ago it was a
month ago yesterday in my work
communicating research and particularly
that research to press I saw a massive
reaction to it lots of reporters wanted
to talk to you all can you tell us a
little bit more about your lives since
you published that paper what the
scientific community is reaction to it
has been and maybe new collaborations
it's it's generated Jason could you
start for us sure life has been super
hectic since the paper was published but
in a good way
we've got a lot of requests initially
for the the coordinates so for the
digital representation of the structure
itself so we were emailing 10 20 people
a day the coordinates for different
researchers around the world to do
virtual drug screening developments in
in silico of antibodies or new proteins
that can bind lately we've just been
constantly shipping the plasmid that we
use to express the stabilized spike
protein and we've even been able to ship
some small amounts of the purified spike
protein itself so that's been really
busy in the lab and then just doing I'm
over 40 different interviews and
articles and q and A's and just trying
to get information
announcer to the public about what's
going on what we've done and what the
future looks like thanks Jason Barney
how has it looked for you in the past 30
days I think my timeline goes back to
around June 6 when we heard it could be
a corona virus coming out of China and
then we got the sequences on the night
of January 10th and since then it's been
24/7 trying to make protein develop
assays start clinical trials do the
animal studies to support the clinical
trials and clinical development and
communicating with a large number of
people not just journalists but
coordination with with global
organizations and US government
organizations I wanted to talk a minute
a little bit about the vaccine
specifically that's in in the clinical
trial that started this week in Seattle
obviously there are several different
types of vaccines but the one that your
research helped to support is an mRNA
vaccine Barney could you explain to the
audience what an RNA vaccine is and and
what its benefits are mRNA is messenger
RNA it's transcribed or copied from our
from DNA
typically this coronavirus has a genome
that's made from RNA and once we knew
the sequence we we could make the
protein we wanted stabilized in the way
we wanted and knowing the structure was
as we did it told us that the protein
was in the right conformation that was
extremely helpful to push this forward
because we didn't have any antibody
reagents to test the structure of the
spike we only knew it was right because
of the structure so mRNA then once that
sequence gets into the hands of a
company Moderne who makes mRNA they
designed their
product so that when it's injected it
can go into a muscle cell and then
inside that muscle cell it will provide
the code to make the protein the spike
protein and that spike protein will go
to the surface of the muscle cell show
itself to the immune system great at
this time I want to give a shout out to
our viewers we have a lot of people
watching today from a lot of different
places and one of our viewers is
actually watching from the international
space station to give a shout out to
James Bell who's viewing today
and remind the audience to please put
your questions in the comments we really
want to get to them today that's amazing
me James yeah you're probably the safest
one on earth he's not on earth I want to
talk a little bit about other
coronaviruses we know that they're out
there immers and and SARS are some that
viewers may be familiar with why why
haven't we tested a MERS vaccine in
human trials it's still circulating in
the Middle East it's still a problem
there can you talk about that Barney yes
that experience we had with the Zika
vaccine in 2016 we made a DNA vaccine
for that because we could control it but
after that experience we started working
with Madonna and mRNA and the purpose in
fact was to develop a MERS vaccine and
we did make a MERS spike vaccine with
mRNA and shown have shown that it's
working in mice at least there was never
enough impetus behind that to take it
into GMP manufacturing so we could
actually give it to people it's very
hard to invest that type of resources
when it's a regional problem merges a
problem mostly now in the Middle East it
doesn't spread that easily and so for
regional diseases it's been hard to
convince people how important it is to
solve those problems
are there any corollaries with with SARS
where we don't have a vaccine either
eight years after that outbreak why do
we think we'll be more successful with a
vaccine for the novel coronavirus well
now we have a structure and after SARS
we really didn't know what we were doing
making vaccine antigens blindly and
after MERS happened we made a decision
based on our RSV experience that Jason
and I on Peter Quang worked on in those
early 2010's and we made a decision if
we ever have to face this again we need
to know what we're doing so we started
solving structures and found ways to
solve them something you know had a
number of serendipitous steps along the
way but the structures got solved we
know a lot about the spike protein now
and a lot about how antibodies
neutralized in terms in terms of
structures and the importance of being
able to study them Jason how how
important is it that young people get
involved in in the work that you're
doing I mean are there a lot of people
already doing this or would you put out
a call to action for more scientists to
be focused on no real structural
investigation to inform therapies
there's a lot of structural biologists
out there we can certainly use more the
fields expanding is new technologies
grow such as cryo-electron microscopy
they allow us to really make these
beautiful structures so this is the
corona virus fight protein and so we
have this map we know where all the
residues are and then we can start to
design in specific mutations to improve
the stability of the protein to boost
expression levels we can truncate
regions that we think aren't going to
elicit a robust immune response and so
having these maps allows for a real
rational engineering approach and I
think the the field of structural
vaccinology is really blooming and a lot
of new people are entering it's nice
structure yeah it's pretty cool and
Jason nets that model you have the 3d
print is about 10 million times larger
than the AK
for protein it's amazing to be able to
understand that level of detail yeah
yeah when you're looking at structures
through cryo-em what are some of the
biggest surprises that you you find
Jason what what does the technology
really let you see that that has
surprised you one of the things that
Crowley am is a lot as to visualize are
some of the dynamics of the of the
spiked protein so perhaps other
techniques like x-ray crystallography we
might end up trapping the molecule on
one conformation within the crystal
lattice whereas with Crowley and we're
looking at individual single particles
and then classifying them into different
groups that maybe have different
confirmations or motions and and we saw
that with the with the spiked protein
there's actually one of these domains
that can move up and down and we can see
that type of motion via cryo-em
and that ends up being very important to
the coronavirus entry the spike has
three receptor binding domains and it
sort of hides them away from the immune
system and then occasionally we'll flick
them up in order to bind the receptor
and those dynamics are important we
think that once all three receptor
binding domains become bound to a
receptor that triggers the
conformational rearrangement that leads
the fusion of the viral membrane with
the host cell membrane which then causes
the cell to become infected I now want
to go to an audience question from
Michelle Aubry token solace and the
question is so far are there any known
side effects from this mRNA based
vaccine we know that the trials have
just started maybe this is an
opportunity to talk a little bit about
the mouse work that's also been done on
this vaccine there's been several mRNA
vaccines taken into clinical trials by
multiple different companies and there's
not been a lot of local or systemic side
effects from those vaccines Moderne has
done seven or eight clinical trials with
a vaccine products against infectious
diseases and it was on the basis of that
safety data that from their prior trial
miles that we were able to start to
phase one trial as quickly as we did and
what about when these vaccines are
tested in in animals do the animals
respond to to the novel coronavirus mice
in particular in the same way that
humans do
because we were able to make the protein
so quickly we've started experiments
both with protein spike and mrna
expressed spike so the protein we make
in the lab protein from the mRNA the
mice make in their muscle cells and
we've already gone through about 6 weeks
of that those experiments and we know
that the mice are making antibody
responses even after the first dose and
much higher antibody responses after the
second dose there's no evidence of any
kind of illness or disease or side
effects in the mice that we've been able
to see so far ok we have a lot of
questions coming in from viewers so I'm
gonna move to to the next one now this
is from Kathleen Jones she's a high
school science teacher and she asks what
resources can I provide to my students
to expose them to this information
including the structural information
that they can understand so some lay
language resources both on the
importance of understanding viral
structure and how that can inform
vaccine development Jason maybe we can
start with you sure a number of
companies are creates pretty cool
resources imagery videos on my Twitter
account I posted a really cool molecular
animation but a large system is made
using some of the models of the spike
and really beautiful renderings and how
it interacts with host cell receptors so
I think we're seeing a lot more
development of those types of imagery
for the general public the coordinates
themselves of the structure are
deposited at the protein databank wwr
CSV org people can download the
coordinates visualize that
using software such as pi mall and
others and really start to spin it
around look at it much like I was doing
with the 3d print they can look at that
on their laptops even on their phone
they can it can do some of that and feel
free to shoot me an email I can try to
put some information out there and I
work with high school students before
who used 3d printers and that
information Jason explained to make
their own 3d models of the F protein
that we did back and published in 2013
so I think there's ways for high school
students either through software or
through 3d printing to really start
getting into how structural biology and
viral molecules are put together Arnie I
think it's just being you we lost Megan
okay well I have a question for you
great okay what are the next steps how
long is the Phase one clinical trial
last and when would a phase two be
started the phase one has already
started we enrolled for people on Monday
and for people on Tuesday of this week
and you know we'll be getting samples
from them over the coming weeks and
we'll use that information plus the
information from animal studies we do
both in small animals like mice or
larger animals like non-human primates
and then try to advance this if we see
no evidence of harm and we do see
evidence that it could work
we would advance it to what's called a
phase 2 trial which would be several
hundred people instead of a forty five
people who are in this early trial and
at at the same time all these things are
being done in parallel the manufacturing
process is being scaled up the
regulatory documents are being developed
the clinical protocols are being
developed and the animal models are all
going on in parallel so that the whole
if everything goes smoothly we could be
in a
larger-scale trial with thousands of
people by before next winter in the
northern hemisphere if that can happen
then we would have a chance of learning
whether this vaccine works or not and in
just within that one-year period and
that would give not only this vaccine
confidence but it would give confidence
to other vaccine modalities that are
being developed they move forward and
scale up in a more rapid way so that you
know maybe by a year or a year and a
half from now we would be able to have
vaccines more available for the general
public
and like I said vaccine development is
usually a decade's long process so this
would be if everything goes completely
smoothly over the next year to year and
a half that's great welcome back Megan
thanks guys thanks for keeping it going
a day in the life of technology but we
have another question and I think this
viewer is wanting to understand the
importance of your research as it
informs the basic science efforts in the
country Ryan Gray is asking if you could
tell us how much of cryo-em scope costs
and give us an estimate of how much
scope time and cost of time it took to
get to the structure could you talk
about that Jason yeah the electron
microscopes are pretty expensive in the
millions of dollars depending on which
model then you need to have a facility
sort of designed around them with the
proper infrastructure they generate
terabytes of data per day so then we
need a lot of computational resources
which is something I'm constantly
meeting with folks here at UT - how to
handle terabytes of data how to maintain
them what to do with waste how to
archive it to preserve it then we have
facility managers these are highly
qualified people with PhDs and keep the
microscopes aligned and running and help
troubleshoot trained new users so the
initial investment is in the five to ten
million dollar range and then we're
looking at around maybe four to five
hundred thousand dollars per year in
service contracts salaries so it it
really adds up and it can get quite
expensive so we do need a lot of support
there but the facilities at UT have been
fantastic another question from a viewer
on a different topic
Janet Fox asked what exactly is it that
causes even healthy people to succumb to
kovat 19 is it only immunosuppression
that's a very good question and we're
just learning about this particular
virus but in other respiratory viruses
that we understand better this is
basically a race between the virus
growth in your lung and the T cell or
immune responses responding to that
virus growth and you know if the T cells
get there a day earlier you may not have
much disease if the T cells get there a
day later you may have a lot of disease
and so this is this is one of the
reasons and bases for vaccinations we
want to educate your immune responses to
be there a day or two earlier than they
would be ordinarily and that it's what
allows you to clear the virus before it
causes much damage then we have a
comment from a student in a lab who's
analyzing this actually a professor
who's analyzing your paper together with
his students CJ wolf Slager
at the University in Delft he asks any
knowledge if the corona virus undergoes
antigenic shift or drift similar to
influenza yeah buddy you might take this
one well it evolves it's not gonna
evolve quite as fast as influenza does
another coronavirus researcher Mark
Denison at Vanderbilt University showed
that corona viruses actually have a
editing function it's the first RNA
virus found to have editing function
within their polymerase that makes their
copies the RNA so it doesn't make as
many mistakes as
other RNA viruses like the ones we
studied before like RSV or or even
influenza so it's going to drift and
it's going to be different but and
there's going to be new corona viruses
that come that would be slightly
different so we'll have to figure out
how to make more generalizable
approaches to corona virus vaccinology
alright it looks like we're getting all
the questions about mutations and
whether as the virus continues to spread
in humans whether the vaccine would
remain efficacious any thoughts on that
given the the rate of mutations we've
observed so far and genome sequences
well you know it's we don't know enough
to say this for sure yet but we do know
that even some of the proteins that
we've made based on the original SARS
one protein or some SARS like viruses
that are can be found in bats we know
that we can generate immune responses
that at least partially cross-react with
this new corona virus now the individual
antibodies are not quite as potent as
they are to the original SARS in terms
of blocking their entry but I think
there's ways that we can design vaccine
our viral proteins to have a breath that
would eat least within the clade be of
beta corona viruses protect us against
that group of viruses so the question is
can we find approaches that could allow
us to have products for clade C for
clade a for alpha corona viruses and I
think those kinds of studies can be done
using structured guided design
Barney Jason we have a comment from a
student at the Simons electron
microscopy Center in New York City she
wanted to know this is Laura Yan en that
they're doing a journal Club on your
paper next week so yet another group who
will be studying your work you like it
I think a lot in the a lot of people in
the audience may be interested as I am I
have young children to know a little bit
more about you know the future of this
vaccine it's only being tested in adults
now but when it would be tested in
younger people and what do you
anticipate at that time the first trials
are but in people between 18 and 55
years of age who are relatively healthy
but very quickly as long as things look
like the vaccine is working that it's
safe we'll expand those trials to older
people and to younger people the
experiments in younger animals and older
animals has already begun and that the
expectation would be that we would would
move those studies into younger and
older people and now a question from
Abbas Baca would this accelerated pace
of vaccine development and approval set
a precedent for future vaccines of the
same type but using different mRNA
sequences yeah I think that's true fine
I'll just jump in there for a second I
think the idea for some of these nucleic
acid-based vaccine is is to develop a
platform and once the platform is
developed and many of the kinks are
worked out in terms of delivery and
stability then it becomes relatively
easy to pop in and out the open reading
frames and coding for the antigen one of
the things that we're trying to
accomplish here
in a more generalized way is that we
think to deal with future problems or
even current problems that are not
solved yet unmet means that you have to
can combine precision vaccinology with
rapid platform manufacturing so if you
have structures if you know exactly how
to make the vaccine antigen that we call
an immunogen
and then you have a vaccine platform for
manufacturing that can allow you to make
it rapidly and deliver it in a way that
can work then combining those two
concepts
we think could be a way forward for
future problems like this Jason Barney
Jenny Brennan is asking what has been
the role of veterinary research in
assisting with the development of this
vaccine could you talk a little bit
about that well almost everything we do
is preceded by doing animal modeling so
in in the sense that we have
veterinarians working side by side with
this some of our lab people are
veterinarians who've gotten also PhDs
and you know veterinary medicine is very
important here there's also a lot of
veterinary Carano viruses that cause
widespread economic problems especially
in pigs and so I think the solutions
that we're finding here could be
relevant to the solutions for veterinary
problems and we're living in a one
health world now that means human health
animal health and ecological health are
all working together and we need to
solve all that at the same time so I see
that we've reached at 9:30 I want to ask
you both a question a question we could
ask anybody watching today and it may be
a different facet but how is the need
for social distancing as we're all
trying to do that as much as we can
affected you both in the work that you
are continuing to do at your labs and
elsewhere it can can we start with you
Barney well you see I'm working from
home today but our biggest concern is
that the people in our lab group who are
mostly young people can keep coming to
work without either being infected or
quarantine and so figuring out that
figuring out the supply chain for our
development work and assay development
those kind of things are different than
what we usually have to face and
processes like this about you Jason it's
actually pretty good
traffic slow parking is really easy our
lab is exempt from some of the shutdowns
so we're just here labs mostly made up
of grad students and postdocs who are
young so everybody's been continuing to
come in getting to FedEx and shipping
things has been a little tricky so we're
driving chewing from FedEx facilities to
pick up and ship packages but yeah
otherwise we're just moving forward well
thank you both for all that you're doing
to continue to move forward now we are
going to start to wrap up our event
today Jason do you have any last remarks
anything that you want to leave the
audience with yeah but we're gonna get
through this we have a lot of people
around the world working on on
interventions the social distancing is
definitely going to help as well have
numerous vaccines being tested
antibodies isolated small molecules and
clinical trials but I think we're we're
well prepared we've been working on
coronaviruses for a long time that the
global we the scientific community just
hang in there
keep practicing for a different thing
and we're good thanks Jason Barney I'd
like to just make two brief points one
is the importance of basic research in
supporting our ability to respond to
problems like this this all started with
just the simple desire to want to know
the structure of the pre fusion F
protein of RSV and that led to epitope
discovery and a vaccine development that
looks like it's progressing through into
the advanced development and that is the
basis for this concept used here of
stabilizing the spike glycoprotein so
one thing is the importance of basic
research the other two investment in
basic research we need to specifically
invest in things that can help us be
better prepared there are technology
now really developed over the last ten
years that make it possible for us to
have prototype approaches for each virus
family or genera that would allow us to
not only be better prepared but to
respond faster we responded very quickly
to this because we've been studying
chrono viruses for seven years we
already know what's what mutations to
make to stabilize the protein if this
had been an arena virus or a Bunya virus
or some things that are less well
studied we would have taken a few years
probably to even get in Phase one so I
think there needs to be investment in
pandemic preparedness and there needs to
be investment and recognition that this
all started from basic research Thank
You Barney yes the situation absolutely
underscores the importance of basic
research this is a message that we try
to communicate the importance of that
from triple-a s and science as well
thank you so much to both of our guests
today we learned about where we are in
vaccine development for the novel
coronavirus how that compares to back
past vaccine development and as Barney
was just alluding to how basic research
helped us get here so quickly for kovat
19 - phase 1 trials already at least for
one candidate you can find a link to the
paper that we referenced in our science
Facebook live discussion comments I wish
everyone watching safety and health and
days ahead be well bye for now